So welcome, everyone,
and in my talk,
I will discuss some aspects
of Shiny open source,
but before we move
on, let me briefly
remind you why our Community
praises Shiny so much.
So, first of all, you can
prototype your applications
very fast.
So you can create
your first POC
in a matter of hours
rather than days.
That all comes
wrapped in a neat user
interface powered by bootstrap.
So you don't really need
to reinvent the wheel
when it comes to the styling.
Obviously, we can customize
it as it was shown
in the previous presentations.
Shiny leverages the
power of hardware
when it comes to
the data analysis.
So in the backend, you can
use those powerful packages
from the tidyverse family, for
instance, and Shiny also.
And it's nice to integrate
that with a large number
of visualization packages like
ggplot2, leaflet, Data.Table,
and even more interactivity.
So how different UI
components talk to each other
is quite easy to understand.
But with all those
advantages in mind,
sometimes I have
impression that we
forget that the true power
of Shiny lies in the fact
that this is fully
open source software.
And I came to
realize that recently
when I was like reading
again through the blog
post describing the
winning solutions
to the second annual
Shiny contest.
And I realized for how
many different applications
you can actually use Shiny.
So here we have an
interactive data storytelling.
We have a machine learning
backed application
for visualizing
your musical taste.
We have data analysis dashboard
that presents the most
popular GitHub repositories.
And finally, you
can even make games
as proven by our very own Pedro.
But all of that wouldn't
be really possible
without all of those,
like Shiny extensions
that are available now.
And every year
there's even more.
And more of them.
So there is no way that
I could cover all of them
in detail during
my 10 minute slot.
But I decided to cherry pick
with just a few,
without which I can't
even start thinking about,
I starting developing my
own Shiny applications.
So let's kick off with
shinyJS, which
is a package from
Dean Attali that
lets you perform common
useful JavaScript
operations in Shiny like hiding
elements, disabling inputs,
resetting values, or alerting
some variables that I often
use for debugging myself.
The cool thing, though,
is that you don't really
need to know any
JavaScript to start
using that because everything
is wrapped in R functions that
are nicely documented.
So it's quite easy
to get started.
Then we have Shiny
widgets, which is basically
a collection of extra
components to enhance
your Shiny applications,
the repository
contains a big selection of
the components that are usually
nicely documented with
little code snippets such
that you can copy
and paste the code
and adjust it for your own needs.
Some of my favorite
elements are, for example,
ticker input, those
fancy checkbox button
or horizontal
multiple-choice selection.
Then we have a small but
rather powerful package,
shinyccsloaders,
that helps you
with adding a loading
animations to the output
instead of blanking them out.
So I mentioned to you already
that Shiny uses this powerful
part for data analysis.
But but certain actions
can take a while.
So it's better to provide
our user with some feedback
that there is something
happening in the background.
So you can do it with
simple one function
call withSpinner that
that adds to your Shiny
those like little animations.
OK, and I wouldn't be myself
if I haven't mentioned
about some packages that help
you style your apps. At Appsilon,
we care a lot about
how the apps look.
So starting from the left,
we have bs4Dash
that provides you with
Bootstrap for admin,
for your dashboards.
Then we have shinyMobile that
helps you create mobile-ready,
Shiny apps that look almost
like native apps for iOS
and Android.
And then on the right, we
have our own shiny.semantic
that helps you to attach
an alternative look
to your Shiny applications.
OK, and I mentioned that I
just scratched the surface
here, so there is even more
fantastic Shiny extensions
that you can find on this
Shiny Awesome repository
that I discovered recently.
And this little repository
summarizes and categorizes
various Shiny extensions
such that you can always find
something that you need there.
I encourage you to check it out.
OK, but using all those Shiny
extensions is just like one way
how you can take advantage
of Shiny open source-ness,
but you can help yourself
with building those tools.
So first of all, you
can start from something
as simple as reporting
it back or bringing
some new idea to the table by
creating a new issue on GitHub
repository or emailing
the author of the code.
But remember to be respectful
with that, as very often
open source code is created by
enthusiasts, or as in our case,
this is something that we
do outside of our daily work
with clients.
Then if you feel
comfortable enough
actually to fix some bug or
contribute with a new idea
to a certain package, feel
free to do some coding
and create a new pull request.
But remember first about reading
the contributing guidelines
as they usually contain
useful information with what
to do or not to do on
a given repository.
Remember about testing
all of your changes
so that you see that
you didn't break
all the previous
functionalities of the code,
and always ask
politely for a review.
It's good to have
another pair of eyes
to see to check the
quality of your code.
OK, but now if you
still see that there
is no solution to your
problem available,
then you can move on
and think about creating
your own package.
And remember that, for
starters, it doesn't really
need to be perfect as
some solution is better
than no solution whatsoever.
And and always you
may find someone
in the community who would be
interested in collaborating
and moving the project forward
if you don't really have time to
do all the coding on your own.
And then a couple
of tips from me:
remember, about adding
tests to your package
from the early beginning,
as it will really
spare you so much troubles
at the later stage
of the development.
Remember about documenting
your code. For you
it might be quite obvious how to
use your own functions, but not
necessarily for the
users of your package.
And recently, it
became a good practice
to add interactive examples
to your repository such
that users can test
what this package actually
can help them with before
they can even download it.
And then comes the fun part.
So remember about publishing
it, sharing with others to get
credits and acknowledgments.
It's a really satisfying feeling.
OK, with that, let me mention
our very own Appsilon open
source family related
to Shiny.
So you have a
variety of packages
here related to
styling packages that
help you with debugging,
translations, and routine.
I will not go into too
much detail here as
we have a separate
prerecorded video available
where I discuss some
of the possibilities
of those packages, and a
little bit more details.
Just let me mention
here that every year,
we try to extend this least.
So stay tuned as later
on Phillip and Marek
will tell you a little bit more
about our two new projects.
OK, so to like prove to you
that our packages can be useful,
a couple of months
ago, we decided
to challenge ourselves
and try to implement
a fully functional Shiny
application in less
than 24 hours.
So here you have the
screenshots from two
out of like six entries
to this little competition
for the comprehensive list
of all the amazing solutions
you can check our blog post.
And if you can't
wait and you still
want to see all of our
packages in action,
I encourage you to visit
the shiny.tools website
that we set up recently.
And it contains
references to the GitHub,
to the documentation, and live
examples of all R packages.
So we can test
them if they can be
useful for your
Shiny development.
OK, so that's all I get.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
Feel free to bring me if
you have any questions,
and I hope you will enjoy
the rest of the session.
Cheers